for more on this joined by former
England and Liverpool footballer John
Barnes hey John it's good always good to
see you thanks for joining us we talked
about this constantly and if nothing
ever seems to change because it's a
problem in society and not football
anymore we just talked about it in
football the more society absorbs itself
we were then told that football can do
something for 90 minutes in the stadium
no racist abuse what can football do
about somebody on a Monday night the
Tuesday afternoon on their phones with
social media this is a social problem it
is so as much as yes they may be many
Nikes fans before their men and I could
find your members of society until we
targeted society and put together an
educational program to let people know
why it's wrong to be racist rather than
blaming social media or blaming football
it'll continue indeed sir so what what
do we need to do how as a greater
society we've got his colleagues
tweeting and saying how outraged they
are I'm guessing that we need the FA to
get involved as well the club has said
what they want to say what do we need to
do as a society what can the FA do if
somebody wants to go on his phone what
responsibility is the FA of stopping a
member of society from going on his
phone and raychel abusing someone that's
got nothing to do with football nothing
to do with the FA what we have to do to
make people know why it's wrong to be
racist not think of laws to stop them
doing it because a lot I'm gonna change
anything if you talk about you did the
point I was listening to the program
just the minute talk about jihadi Jack
now if you're talking about and of
course just bear with me a second we
talked about members of Isis having an
ideology passing laws isn't gonna change
that ideology racism is an ideology and
passing laws is gonna change that so we
have to come up with something different
kick it out and these programs have been
around for 20 years spending millions of
pounds and it's getting worse so
therefore we have to stop just throwing
it to a football store because we for
example if that is that troller is a
milkman yes he's a football fan but he's
a milkman are we gonna say the
institution of milkman are racist no so
why do we say the institution of
football is it is a societal problem and
we have to calculate in society
yeah but how well first of all by
letting people know why it's wrong to be
racist and why why why we all are
racially biased to certain extent based
on what of course it's a very nuanced
situation and of course it's
we've had 300 years of indoctrination
and just by saying it's wrong to be
racist because we're all created equal
it's not the answer first of all you
have to let people or why they think the
way they do to begin with because of
what history has wrongly shown them
about different groups be they wouldn't
be there homosexual to blue they black
people so it's gonna take a long time
but we have to start rather than just
thinking of laws yeah you say it's gonna
take a long time and we started off by
saying that we've been talking about
this for a long time it doesn't seem to
have moved it seems to be stuck we seem
to be stuck in our ways I mean a lot of
people who were watching this afternoon
will say well I'm not racist what would
you say to them in responders well I'm
sure unfortunate we are all biased to a
foot to a certain extent now when you
talk about either racism sexism
homophobia is because of what we have
been wrongly told about different groups
of people you as a woman would
understand that form of sex with an
understand that black people to
understand that now why I say we're all
biased be racially homosexually or
sexist because of what we have been
wrongly taught about different groups of
people something as simple as saying if
I was going to go to war when I'd rather
go to war with their skin and with
tattoos or with a woman now of course
I'm not gonna say who I'd rather go to
war with because then it will be call
upon for me to be sacked and put in
prison if I really said what I feel but
we know how we truly feel because we
have been wrongly shown the capabilities
of certain groups of people and we have
to dismantle that and deconstruct what
we have learned which is gonna take a
long time but we haven't started to do
it all we've started to do is talking
about banning people and finding people
and coming up with laws to stop people
being discriminating yes we're talking
about race but it couldn't be from a
from a from a female point to girl for a
moment sectional point of view so it's a
long long process but we've not even
started it yet and once again people are
talking about it being footballs problem
now we were then told for 90 minutes in
the stadium we can erase is chanting and
I suppose football can control that to a
certain extent but what can football do
about somebody when they're at home on
their phone they've gone the I mean if
there's talking about footballers now
now boycotting social media so
footballers don't want social media
what's gonna stop a racially biased
person still abusing people on social
media be abusing footballers yeah but I
hey but do you not think to some extent
Twitter and other social media does have
a responsibility to make sure that if
people are racially abusive that they
have to
suffer the consequences absolutely but
then here we are we're now winding it -
first of all it's not just football
now it's Twitter and where else is it
gonna be it's everywhere we all have a
responsibility because of course it's
not going to be Twitter it'll be in some
other form and then that some sort of so
we all have a responsibility to try and
change but as long as we just keep
pointing the finger at football as we
were
I'm glad Twitter's now been added
because there's somebody else who we can
now point the finger at but let's look
at ourselves and say how do we really
feel about the society we live in and
the people in our core members of that
society so yes the point I'm trying to
make is that we all have a
responsibility
so rather than now coming down hard on
Twitter coming down hard on football
it's gonna be somebody else's turn next
we all have to look at ourselves and how
do you think pompe should deal with this
well Paul promised to play football
that's what he should do and of course
yes you can come out and speak against
it
Paul pública what can I do to change
racially biased people's minds about
black people if you score the hatchet
for Manchester United maybe Man United
fans are like import Padma can't do
anything to change the racial climate
what has to happen is that we have to
have these conversations but people have
to be honest with themselves about how
they truly feel don't stop pointing the
finger and stop just pointing the finger
of football because once again here we
are now saying that and I'm saying this
football has not got a chance of
changing people's perceptions football
can't do it society has to do 10
football's of the part of that okay well
we've got you let's end on a lighter
note should we how is it being one of
Harry's Heroes well unfortunately I was
just the assistant manager to Harry
which meant that a lot of work to do and
we're hoping to have a new series and
I'm hoping to beef it for the second
series to possibly play if not I'll have
to be assistant again but it was it was
great it was great to catch up with the
boys and I think that we saw the human
factor of footballers because you know
as much as we're looking at high profile
footballers now in terms of their
celebrity life that they lead
I think if you look at some of the older
players you can see that they're just
normal people who you know do normal
things and he still got those shorts the
shorts on the 80s on the show from Harry
the Shaw some be a traffic me anymore
and I've still got the shots of Harry's
hero
big bag yeah yeah